alright last topic hey Skye Jess Skye
judge last topic Ono Beckham jr. yeah we
heard some of the chatter last week he
had that vague response to a question
about his future in Cleveland
then came the story from Mary Kate Cabot
the Cleveland Plain Dealer
that according to unnamed sources he's
being wasted in a dysfunctional offense
then came the news he needs sports
hernia surgery then came J Glazers
report that Odell Beckham jr. is telling
people from other teams coaches and
players he wants out of Cleveland it
looks like he's not gonna be with the
Browns neck well yeah I don't know what
to think of it there you know again I
mean have they optimized what they
thought are optimized what they could
get out of Odell Beckham jr. in that
often certainly not who's to blame
Freddie kitchens I think it has to start
there yeah it starts there you know it
goes it goes to Baker Mayfield to I
think who's missed them a few you know a
few times in every game and then I'm
gonna put a little blame on Odell
Beckham jr. for not being there in OTAs
and things like that too
so it goes around don't don't get me
wrong you know I love obj but I'm not
gonna be painful to you well yeah bison
one day you've called out your heroes
well yeah you've told that Aaron Rodgers
that the Scotch bid is overplayed and
now you're saying that obj should have
been there for a season perfect I can't
be real with those two guys who know
that I am the presidents of both of
their fan clubs that nobody can be real
with them that's all I'm trying to say
there but I guess the one listen I knew
he was banged up I had heard from a lot
of people that he was never hasn't been
a hundred percent healthy the whole year
he was bit died battling with things in
pre-season when I was there during
training camp and then you know I think
the thing that troubles me the most is
just the Jay Glazer stuff Jay is
connected Jay talks to a lot of players
he's got a lot of coaches there he's
heard this somebody from somebody
directly and it doesn't take much it
doesn't all it takes is Beckham saying
it to one of the one guy who's on
Glaser's network and it could be and Jay
Jay's tentacles reach out farther than
that they do because he's involved with
a lot of players with off the field
training and things like that too so you
know that's to me where is it is a
little bit troubling
I would think Odell would be happy and
Cleveland from the standpoint of there's
a lot of things to be happy about as far
as the future there I mean Baker
Mayfield I still believe in him he's
there and a locker next to his best
friend Jarvis Landry you know there's
talent on that office Nick Chubb is
arguably the best running back in
football so you know and we'll see what
happens when the coaching you know
they're coaching department I don't know
if that's gonna be a factor I think that
will be a big factor because I think he
desperately wants to create something
like the Patriots or just play for the
Patriots but he sees how buttoned up the
Patriots organization is and he sees how
undisciplined the Browns are and and
look I want to go a level higher I mean
John Dorsey is a great identifier of
talent he is but you also have to be
somebody who understands how all that
talent is gonna operate when you put it
into a locker room and you shake it up
yeah right they all that you have to you
have to have a team right you have to
have and we said this about the Cowboys
last week that the Jared Steven Jones
have put together a great group of
talented players but the hole is not
greater than the sum of the parts that's
what you need and there's too many
dysfunctional personalities yeah in that
Cleveland locker room and when you throw
a head coach who's admittedly learning
on the fly that's not the way to get the
best possible team no yeah I mean you're
right I think to your point you know
that does the decisions that John Dorsey
is gonna have to make you know after
this season because I do think you know
with Freddie kitchens learning on the
fly and I think John Dorsey was put in a
tough spot won you know he couldn't let
Freddie kitchens just walk out the door
and go somewhere else because if he went
somewhere else and had another great
years an offensive coordinator everybody
in the world would have gone hey what
the hell why did we keep Freddie
kitchens he's an off exactly and he
knows how to work with Baker Mayfield
everything like that he's the danger you
hire a defensive coach last year yeah
and and it keeps working yeah then this
is the year that you lose Freddie
kitchens like what they had to make the
coach exactly you also have to know when
to pull the plug yes right and I would
think that that is certainly a big
conversation with the Cleveland Browns
right now whether you know Freddie
kitchens is that right guy to lead them
into the future and maybe you know if
they're if not yeah they need to find
that personality who can blend the
locker room together and pretty much say
hey no I'm the new sheriff in town you
know I love all you guys personalities
but we're gonna keep it in check right
here we're not gonna cross this line
like Baker you will not be talking about
the training staff and you know
shouldn't have to
tell him I I get it I know what he just
he's young and he's honest yeah I don't
care I know you can be honest and still
be done he's trying to stick up for
Odell that's what he's really trying
no but but look and we hear we hear
about this with the Eagles it's it's him
it's emotional intelligence yeah and I
thought Baker Mayfield got it he's still
immature and you wonder how much of it
is immaturity and how much of it is he's
just an [ __ ] yeah what right yes
there's a chance he's just an [ __ ]
yeah those are things [ __ ] set right
yeah I know we like Baker Mayfield and
we like to have access to him right
let's be real if he's gonna be real
we're gonna be well but he said
yesterday something an [ __ ] says so
either he's immature and he doesn't
realize he said something [ __ ] issue
or he's an [ __ ] yeah I I would go
with him immature you know I think he's
got just the right he's an [ __ ] well
I think he's got just the right amount
of [ __ ] why we're saying this for it
so much on pft ot today I'm really
enjoying it to be a really great
quarterback I don't think he is a true
all-around life [ __ ] I don't I think
he's just young he's brash you know he's
a Texas gunslinger and went to Oklahoma
and won the Heisman and everything kind
of been good the last few years and this
is the first year he's had to deal with
some skepticism and people questioning
him and everything like that and yes he
just hasn't handled it all perfectly
that's that's the biggest problem but I
still love him as a quarterback I'm not
ready to go down [ __ ] [ __ ]
tendencies to run a team yes you need to
be able to yell and write at the right
time right but you can't go up and
calmly call out the training staff that
is that's a dick move it is you know but
it is but to me so he's either immature
he's an [ __ ] or he's a dictation and
it's immature because we've heard coming
out in the draft too that you couldn't
he was the most well-liked quarterback
anybody had ever seen by the training
staff at Oklahoma the weights tap all
and they loved him I think you know and
again I think he loves the trainees out
there in Cleveland I think he just went
overboard with trying to kind of deflect
some criticism of Odell Beckham jr. and
it just went wrong and that that's
really where I'll leave it yeah I look I
know what we love Baker Mayfield we're
just trying we're trying to try to you
know what because the thing is I don't
think he's got everybody in that
organization
that you know is is gonna be as candid
as we are know I know we're trying to
him a favor right cuz I think they mean
by somebody and and here's anything -
here's anything - don't assume J I think
John Dorsey has a role with the Browns
but think about the stories that we've
heard when they made their past to
coaching hires Paul DePodesta wanted
Sean McDermott Dorsey wanted Hugh
Jackson yeah how did that work out yeah
Dorsey wanted Freddie kitchens D Podesta
wanted Kevin Stefanski how's that
working out I just wonder at what point
D Podesta is gonna acquire more
influence in the organization where y'at
ownership should put him in a spot where
you just try you trying to work it out
just right sure because John Dorsey is a
great identifier and evaluator of talent
radar what kind of a team builder is he
there yeah right and maybe you need to
rely on somebody else to help be the guy
that's it build the town that's gonna
work together yeah I get anyway I get
you let's go and you know what
something's holding the Browns back yeah
you're an [ __ ] and I'm proud of it
yeah I've been an [ __ ] for a long
time you are you're the king of hey it's
gotten me this far why stop now
everybody have a great day
well we'll be back again tomorrow what
we need to come up with a show that
works in the board like [ __ ] in front
I think we can work that don't worry you
know it everybody christen an [ __ ]
I'm an [ __ ]
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports